warum ist sowas verantwortungslos wenn
es mehr als einen gibt der um so eine
position so eine wichtige position
streitet das ist immer spannend wenn es
mehr als ein gibt oder wenn es mehrere
gibt wir haben das in der spd auch
hinter uns das belegt die demokratie
aber ich sage ihnen wir sind jetzt vier
monate davor dass die ersten menschen
anfangen werden der briefwahl ihre
stimme abzugeben also man hätte das ein
bisschen besser vorbereiten können
und vor allem sind wir gerade in einer
phase wo wir in der politik in der
bundesregierung diese pandemie zu
bekämpfen haben auch andere politische
entscheidungen stehen noch an und da ist
die union völlig gelähmt ist nicht in
der lage entscheidungen zu treffen und
das finde ich unverantwortlich von zwei
parteivorsitzenden auch von zwei
parteiorganisation dass man sich auf
diesen moment nicht vorbereitet was ist
denn der schaden bitteschön in der
korona politik dass diese woche söder
und laschet miteinander um diesen posten
streiten also was wo soll da der schaden
gewesen sein diese woche der schaden
entsteht doch da dass die menschen
gerade auf die politik gucken und sagen
die streiten dann nur die zerlege sich
wir haben vier stunden in der fraktion
über das infektionsschutzgesetz
diskutiert die union hat vier stunden
über personalquerelen intent ist aber
anschließend über das
infektionsschutzgesetz aber anschließend
über das bis in die nacht rein
wir haben ja aber natürlich ist der
schwerpunkt auch in der öffentlichen
auseinandersetzung ein anderer jeder von
den unions kollegen ist doch gerade aus
seinem wahlkreis beschäftigt mit der
frage wer soll es machen und nicht wie
bringen wir das land durch die pandemie
und das ist ja das wissen sie auch das
ist ja nicht eine normale personale
entscheidung sondern da werden wir
wirklich die messer gewetzt und das ist
doch für eine regierung in einem solchen
zustand nicht gut wenn ein
koalitionspartner und der größere
koalitionspartner gerade faktisch
gelähmt ist also ich meine laschet wird
ja er wird ja nicht unbeschädigt aus
dieser ganzen situation rauskommen noch
mal es gibt ein wunsch den ich ernsthaft
habe und das ist darauf konzentrieren
dass hier noch große dinge zu erledigen
haben in dieser regierung und dann
können die können ihren wahlkampf gern
machen wie sie wollen ja ich hab bin
jetzt auch nicht derjenige der und wie
der union tipps zu geben hat aber es
gibt eine große erwartung und politik
und die sollten wir erfüllen